oh yes about to start ready ready
popcorn but nachos she prepare with red
licorice all right it's time we made a
new movie good idea Scoob but first we
need a trailer oh can you do the
trailers high voice let me give it a
shot in the world destroyed by evil
discover the epic origin story the
greatest team of heroes
of mystery nailed it
[Music]
hi-yah this mangy stray is coming with
me he's not a stray okay then what's his
name his name's are you scooby middle
name doobie last name do you never take
it off maybe don't do that again I'm
Fred
this is Velma hi and that's Daphne hey
I'm Shaggy and this is scooby-doo nice
to meet you
yeah
hello
whoa whoa whoa Shaggy and Scooby were
taken do you realize where we are no
look a real man the clean modernist
thing the cool blue color palette where
in my case did you say I can't nope
I said well can't you just like you
maybe this can lead us to Scooby and
Shaggy trace amounts of moustache oil
twelve-year-old scotch
it's the bad guy my dad
[Music]
[Music]